我們先看題目好不好
我就讓同學練習比較經典性
這去年高考考題
相信大家很多人看過了
無論如何就把題目還是簡介一下它
可以稍微認真聽
就把它當成考前
你就對功能的一個再熟悉
我們看一下題目來
國民體育法就幾條條文
奧林匹科反運動禁藥
然後03年簽署
然後上述該機構追溯期長達10年
我先聊一下我看文字的觀感
就我自己看這個當下覺得
他有點像屁話
就要提到若干東西
但其實都沒有帶到重點
我們再往下走
好近年來選手發出被沾染禁藥
往下
重點的題文應該從這裡著手
行政院與書建
我像這個地方叫小新
他說行政院與書建
我自己讀考題的經驗是
可以稍微做歸納
當你沒有明顯的在題目裡面看到
發文機關跟受文機關
就你沒有看到誰給誰的時候
在走題文的時候都不必真的太嚴肅
因為它有可能是一些廢話
但你如果很嚴肅的看到誰給誰
你就要更謹慎一點
提到現在很明顯的作答線索
行政院
現在這個數別就是數件
就大概肯定要就不能亂改
並複製
所以兩個蠻好的關鍵詞
數件
然後這裡也有複資 所以表示這題應該是要副本
給兩個機關
我們看 請該部
行政院就發給教育部 要做什麼
正式禁藥管制 協同若干機關有作為跟宣導
這個關鍵詞我覺得可以看
宣導跟監控 所以表示
題文應該是重點朝這個方向
行政院給教育部應該 把主要能量聚焦於宣導跟監控
這是我們理解題目一個比較大的重心
結果你要是要先找到誰給誰 做什麼
再去反推
從這一點反推 它前面可能就帶到一些事情的重要性
所以可能國際上很在意禁藥
那我們被驗出的禁藥
就大概是題目啦
所以有選手用禁藥
所以行政院請教育部就處理一下
那我們來看看 今天有四份
同學寫的東西
我就從頭幫各位改一下它
就看老師怎麼看一份卷子來
檔號這應該沒問題
行政院發文機關至中 台北市這個目前都對我們打個勾
教育部確實社文機關也對 所以目前這同學都對
錯在這個地方
我們剛剛在題目時候明顯提到 題文的規定是速件
當然確實是最速件 就是我們剛剛提到的
一旦誰給誰啟動之後
所有的文字都要極度謹慎 太不謹慎就被扣分
主子呢
正式運動管制問題 當然也合理啦
確實是發文的主要目的
所以目前錯在個數別
要扣分喔
平均分如果是10分左右
像這樣可能就很難再十分往上
然後這裡有格式有誤
跨業的時候確實很容易導致格式有誤
其實要控三格 它沒有控
所以這樣扣兩分
說明一 體育違法
抄題目可以 因為近年來的考題大概
傾向說明中抄
近年來接人驗出 這也都是抄
所以就要先肯定它
在說明這個地方
我覺得它完全是狀況
超得不錯
也是考試的趨勢
我就各位可以關注
稍微關注一下
再看辦法
魚霞區可能的販毒
這有點扯啦
他可能錯誤理解題目的意思
結果題目應該是運動禁藥
運動禁藥跟毒品那是
解案不同的東西
所以荷蘭熱點跟茶漆
所以我猜他應該是
不太會寫或題目理解有誤
這肯定會扣大分喔
所以這個辦法以我覺得會
嚴重的扣分
二勒
對於禁藥紀錄的運動有一律禁賽
這個也是個問題
有使用禁藥是否要一律的禁賽
那可能是另一種法規面
所以我猜他應該是對辦法的寫作不怎麼嫌熟
我們再往下趕
所以辦法兩點應該都是會直接導致扣分
正本勒
教育部可以打勾
但副本肯定錯
我們剛剛在提文有提到
有中華奧會
跟另一個機關
所以我們剛好缺到那個負資
隨著一樣又是扣分
好院長 簽字張單沒問題
我們要算一下扣幾分好不好
數別錯
格式錯
辦法兩個都扣分
然後副本該寫不寫
以平均分10分他4個點5個點被扣分
大概就是
6分左右的分數滿可惜
你用宏觀的視野看這樣一份卷子
可以發現應該是個水準以上的考生
大家可能解讀體溫的過程 不夠那麼細膩
所以蠻多人其實他做打的時候可以拿到12分
那這樣一個就是蠻悲哀 最後拿到就一半左右分數
我們當然不是批評他 只是覺得就蠻可惜
就是必分卷子
那各位因為也就沒有上功課很久
透過這樣的過程
也可以去修正自己做打的時候一些樣貌
我們就第一分改完了
希望可以對各位有一點點幫助或者啟發吧
我們現在改第二分好不好
老師 同學說老師曬得好黑喔
曬得好黑
對啊
他就沒事 每天曬太陽
曬得好黑
提到這個曬得好黑喔
提個插曲好了
上禮拜我買一台新的腳踏車
花15萬
美麗達公路車很帥 我就騎它
然後第一天騎出去的時候
就差一個邊打架
我講真的
白木
我騎腳踏車
我會很喜歡下坡的時候騎很快
然後到最後課才減速
就練那種下坡的感覺
不管 反正那紅燈我就停下來
我先停
然後旁邊陸續就有摩托車過來
結果一個男生就載女朋友
應該是女朋友啦
反正就騎GoGo
GoGo
然後就停我旁邊
其實我一開始就對他沒有什麼好感
我覺得
所有上路的車子都要打檔才算是車子
對摩托也要打檔
腳踏車也要
就是GoGo那種電動車
我不是的
很接受
然後不管
看GoGo已經很不爽了
他眼睛又在那邊一直看我
看我車怎麼樣
反正就不是很好感
不管後來他講話了
他可能就回頭跟女生講話
因為在旁邊跟我滿近
話我聽得很清楚
他也沒揍他
你怎麼說什麼
他居然說
哇
外勞
也可以騎公路車
結果我戴口罩
他也可以把我當外勞
有沒有像太郎
還有說兇氣好大
認真一點好不好
今天是公文課
老師你可以看特別的留言
看他會不會同學問得好這樣子
我們可以改第二份喔
皮膚黑是不是
剛剛是第一份嘛 我們先改第二份來
第二份我來按一下灰圖
提文我們就不去看了
我們就直接改來 第二份齁
這大概都對啦齁 發生機關普遍不會有問題
色紋者就要補員隊
速箭上軌道了齁
速箭對齁
提文有規定要速箭齁
請櫃部正式 我們先肯定櫃部好不好 回答的滿上道
在公文內文的過程 我們不太會提到
權嫌 我們都是用軍大櫃部
櫃部是很棒一個作答的水準
我們把它打勾好不好 這個我覺得不錯
可以學它喔 不能用教育部用櫃部
下行文請照辦這個也OK啦 我們就改它的說明
說明我猜應該是沒問題的
它主子寫這麼精確 我覺得說明抄也是我覺得抄得滿上道
都可以 所以目前沒有太多扣分
幾乎都對 而且會引起很大好的觀感
就跪步那是OK的 辦法勒
禁藥管制加強宣導 宣導可以 因為提文確實有提到宣導
禁藥記錄監控 我蠻欣賞這樣做到喔
所以宣導提到
檔號被跳過了 老師 什麼意思
檔號哪裡被跳過
喔對 同學改變還是細
用上方本要檔號跟保存 格式有誤 先扣1分
謝謝老師
同學發現我剛剛沒有改到
格式有誤 少寫齁
但內容我覺得蠻上軌道很棒
主要的關鍵詞都帶著沒有拖泥帶水
正門教育部打勾
復問齁
中華奧會也都對啊
確實有提到 院長也都對
所以整體人他看起來肢體有點潦草
但肢體不管
以簡簡明確的條件去看
我覺得他的節奏控制很棒
然後檔號這個地方沒有寫我猜應該是個不小心
因為整體我覺得它應該是中上以上的水準
像我在月券的時候我可能考慮連這個缺點都不算
因為我覺得那是無心之過
我只能給13分
你會很不滿說
隔四沒寫就13分
剛剛那個很用心就6分
其實我們主要是看
它到底上到不上到
會寫還是不會寫
小地方其實以我而言不在意
起碼我覺得它的專業度
聰明度當個公務員是可以的
OK嗎
老師這邊有同學問到說想問老師
你問什麼
那個說明部分提到2023年
這要寫到同一個格子嗎
數字問題我們把圈講好不好
很多同學就平常下課問老師
數字
於格子裡面的控制大小
整齊就好
請你用整齊跟美觀為原則去寫它
它沒有一定要在一個裡面或者兩個裡面
基本原則在於
真正的公文是用A-Forge去寫嘛
就引印出來
所以在作答公文的時候
不要太拘虐於格子的大小你要把它想像成它如果是一份A-Forge你這樣寫2003它會導致很醜 很難看嗎起碼就這份做到樣貌 我覺得可以接受但你要稍微把它拉長一點點 我也可以接受
所以如果你要結論就是
當你觀測到阿拉伯數字的大小與格子的問題的時候
請自己斟酌 以美感為主就好
或回到我剛剛提到了
我連檔號都不去在意它了 我會在意這個地方嗎
所以我們在意的是它的聰明
是否可以解這一題
但是深論或者選拔人才一個重點
這樣有聽懂嗎
可以啦
那老師這邊還有同學在提
這個要寫到同一個格子內
然後這個題有必須寫辦法嗎
這題我覺得可以寫辦法
這題我剛剛有提到他改的時候蠻欣賞他的辦法
宣導跟監控
我覺得是可以被接受的
但每題因題而異
這題我可以接受他的辦法
那另外想請問老師說
行政院韓的字要多大
這跟剛剛格子是同一種問題
所有字體大小
都請你把它當成空白的A4字
它如果是合乎美觀的
足以判斷的
通常就會被打勾
那英文要寫到同一個格子裡面嗎
那個阿拉伯數字
誰問的
老師你可以看
這邊有一個令
所有格子的問題
請不要再計較格子
正式的公文沒有格子
只要美觀足以判斷即可
所以等一下誰再問我格子的問題
我那個齁
不要讓他打疫苗有沒有
那個莫德納都進來他不能打
直接去打豬流感
不要再問格子的問題
美觀就好
這樣可以嗎
好
第二份
老師這邊還有一個問
他說這個什麼
是否可再說這個大貴
這個什麼
君大貴貴喔
君大貴貴好
君大貴貴我們快速講齁
我們今天其實不是以上課為目的
就簡單談一下月券觀感
但是同樣我們還是樂於回答
我們在公文裡面文書裡面
稱呼對方
不會叫對方全名
就要比你跟我在對話的時候
假設你叫
宋相傑
我不會直接叫你宋相傑
我會叫你宋先生
或者小宋之類的
我們會叫另一種名稱
那樣的名稱反映到公文的時候
如果那個對象是你的長官
我們習慣用軍
假設行政院是我的長官
我會叫他軍院
我不會叫他行政院
OK
如果是給我
通常是上下比較常見
如果是給我部署
像這一題是行政院給教育部
教育部算他的部署
他會叫他貴部
所以如果你沒有這方面的基礎
你可以既作答比較常見的
我們稱呼長官用軍
稱呼部署用貴
無論如何
就是在
內文就主旨說明辦法當中
我們其實不太會稱呼到對方的權名
OK
名稱問題
這是好問題 因為就專業一點 這叫稱謂語
是判斷公文內行跟外行的一個很好的鑑別一個點
所以通常只要看到 會去寫到貴或者均
大概就水準以上 所以你可以發現我剛剛改竹子看到貴的時候
就像看到子己一樣 先圈再講
然後回饋一下 那這個好的做答案
會引起很好的越見觀看
那老師這邊新的同學有在留言是說
如何判斷需不需要寫辦法呢
要看題目
這也是個好問題
通常辦法 我們現在談什麼辦法
辦法就是
假設我行政院寫公文給教育部
我是否叫你做事
我如果叫你做事 那份文書裡面就有辦法
辦法就是做事
那有時候公文 我發文給你不一定叫你做事
我只是通知你 讓你了解某種事情 有可能
所以你可以粗略去分
有些公文是讓你知情的
那他就不會有辦法斷
有些公文是交辦性質的
那可能他就需要辦法斷
他並沒有外顯的線索
必須靠閱讀力
所以他才叫深論作答
所以早期很多人都說
考公文沒有意義
考公文沒有見別度
事實上那是不盡然的
甚至是我覺得
公文在條理上是一眼可以判斷
那個學生的考生的水準是否夠
是滿好一個提醒的
搞定了嗎
搞定 那有一個這個是
一樣的嘛
就是要如何判斷是否写辦法斷
對 一樣問題
好
要回到閱讀力
如果你要一個明顯答案
回到閱讀力去判斷
他發功能給對方
是否明顯叫對方做事
還是只是讓對方知情某一件事情
如果是後者
則不必有辦法斷
有聽到嗎
好
那往下改
好 老師先往下改
那待會有些中文性的問題 我們中訪的時候再提問
我們改第三份啦
第三份喔
第三 剛剛是第2 現在第三
那剛剛這中間的話 有同學問到就是說
是否會有防疫的主題可能是否會考這樣
會呢 防疫我覺得會呢 起碼去年好像警察特考
不知道三等還是四等 好像四等就考到了
我覺得有可能是我會準備一下 防疫有可能
好問題 那我就改齁
現在這邊考卷 如果你在網路上可以看到就很惹人厭
這個格式就是潦草 但確實有蠻多作答者
他是很外行的 倉促準備這個考試
這裡看 我們現在還沒有看內容
大概就覺得有問題 我們就改它來
字體這大小都控制的不是很漂亮
點一下
我們以內容為主了 行政院就OK
打個勾吧
這個錯了 外行
教育部的權限就要教育部啊
他前面把它加上行政業這是很明顯的錯誤
不行喔 扣分喔
而且會不是扣1分2分引起觀感不良
一看就是個外行的作答者
權限使用不當
好 於格式上數別到底對齁
有理解可以啦 肯定他
竹子 哇這字實在有夠醜
什麼 這個完全看不懂 你看
這地方是我想改的
我想去判斷他是否交到貴部
但重點距他居然讓我判斷不當
這可能就會直接扣分啦 我們看齁
說明咧
今年來格式凌亂啦 啟動點的位置一下這裡一下這裡
我覺得就是完全格式問題
內容大概普遍都是抄 我覺得好 內容大概我就不改他可以
但格式應該酌情扣1到2分 嚴重的觀感不良
直接拉扯到正本教育部 副本你看又不寫
這題題目有複製啊
所以我們這樣從初步看就是個外行的
權嫌不大
然後閱讀力
副本沒有看到
格式凌亂
至於他要不要寫半把動 我甚至連改都懶得改他
這一題給我評分喔 5分
比剛剛那 6分更慘
然後這一題我直覺性的觀感
寫個辦法比較好
因為題文他有提到宣導跟監控之類的
然後他又不寫半把
我很難說不寫半把錯啦
只是改成終究是我
我會觀感不了
就不傾向你的高分
我如果打就是4分到5分再打他
我也不會覺得良心不安
因為確實他並沒有很好的態度
去面對這樣一份卷子
所以你的字體跟格式
我覺得還是要拿出一點誠意
這篇的觀感
好來搞定 我覺得篇D有五分
第三篇
老師我們抄個話
這邊有同學在問說
稱長官均稱
部署是貴
那請問大呢
大其實比較少用到
所以剛剛就把我時間不講
如果你這樣聽的話大是
平行機關大喔
我先寫一下大小的大
平行機關裡面
位階比較高的 比如說我舉例好不好
內政部底下有警政署
內政部在這裡 警政署比內政部低一點點
但內政部畢竟是個部
所以如果旁邊出現個部叫交通部
交通部跟內政部都是部一樣大
我們現在談的是 如果交通部跟警政署互動是平行
因為交通部管不到警政署
但交通部畢竟是部長 警政署畢竟是署長
人家部長大一點點
但在那個情況底下就會使用大
所以我們下結論
警政署稱呼交通部就應該叫他大部
理由在於你不是我主管
但行政位階上中就可能比我高一點
用大部
考試比較少用到的
但想聽還是可以聽
那老師這邊有一個同學在問是說
請問是不是跟下屬發文才能用辦法
跟上級報告不用辦法這樣
上行文確實寫辦法的比例很低
但對下屬要不要寫辦法不一定
有些下行文一樣是有可能不用辦法的
所以我可以幫你做歸納
上行普遍是沒有辦法的比例特別高
但下行要不要寫辦法大概一半一半
所以你不能直接說下行就不用寫辦法斷
那是個偏差的觀念可能會導致作答問題
還有嗎
沒有
沒有 那我們就改最後份囉 第十份
那有一些比較特別的議題
就譬如說 如果成為公文高手這種的
老師是待會我們再講還是
等一下再講啊
我們先把第四份改一改
老師 那筆的顏色同學問說可以改筆的顏色嗎
筆的顏色照現行公告黑色跟藍色
黑跟藍兩種
喔喔喔喔 批改顏色 那我換一下好不好
有顏色 有啊
那我改成這個顏色好不好
好
我以為作打顏色啦 我們改這個
這個字體就漂亮喔 字體漂亮觀感就好啊 教育部書件 你看現在目前 欸 書現個錯了小瑕疵 保存極限的正確的格式是保密期限
真的有人會寫保存期限 不要寫保存 保密
錯喔 扣一分喔
但這瑕疵就是不會引起嚴重觀感不良
情有可原的小瑕疵 但還是瑕疵扣分
這就不開心了
貴不美 就一看外行 教育部就不對
部署喔 要叫鬼部齁
期望有誤
所以完全這一看我就要開始又把他定位以為可能是外行的
稱位語不當
期望語不當 下行
他要請合適 對長官才要請合適
所以觀感不良齁
大概知道
主子內文可以用抄 但在小細節就
扣2分 扣1分
再扣再扣
說明1勒
選手染進要好抄
可以接受 就我沒有很欣賞 但加減可以接受
我們再看辦法
奧林批克文會 社有什麼 直接打岔
像這個我覺得 就各位可以多關注
我們剛剛設定所謂的辦法就是 我請你做事
某一件事請你做 寫在辦法
你看他的文字 奧林批克文會社有反經要
該機構社有反經要管理事宜 是做事嗎 那是
我跟你講那個機構在管 又不叫你做事
抄錯 他完全用抄 抄錯
打差
要錯就都錯了
我國若干時間簽 簽署什麼
我國簽署也不叫你做 簽署是早已發生的東西
那也不是明顯交辦的作為
所以即便我認為這題要寫辦法 但他的辦法就是不恰當被扣分
打差齁
所以題目固然蠻多資訊可以讓你利用 但你也不應該抄到不該抄的地方
這個2003我稍微停留一下
因為反映到剛剛有同學問這個問題
我們剛剛有一份卷只是2003擠在同一格
我可以接受
你看這個範例
它用兩個寫它 我也可以接受
所以就可以消失我們剛剛英文字母
數字 格子問題 整齊
看起來蠻漂亮 數字可以接受
但它內容就確實不當
正本咧 這樣也不可以
兩個副本也對 院長
院長通常我們會繞到這個地方比較好
所以他可能寫太右邊
我們盡量拉到左側
所以這是我們今天改的第四份
整體看起來是他有個好的觀念
知道最近很流行是可以用抄的
但辦法抄得蠻糟糕
我猜啦 他應該是不太會寫辦法
甚至如剛剛同學提問的
他不知道要不要寫辦法
一個忐忑就隨便亂抄題目
所以我們再次聚焦於
到底有沒有叫對方做事
這題我的觀感是有
因為他有跟教育部說
你要正視那個問題 你要宣導 你要去監控
所以應該是有這樣做事的可能
是我在作答就會發揮
發揮不當
整體這份評分
竹子扣2分 格式錯 辦法扣大分
這個如果給我評分 即便它格式跟字體我覺得還不錯
6分
甚至會更低
6分 就是
也是我覺得不及格的分數
所以作答觀念還真的是要通透了
好來
那就簡單示範的四份
我覺得就是這段時間來用比較輕鬆
你也不用寫 看看別人錯
老師 這邊在PK的過程中
同學有問幾個問題
然後我這邊依序的再導致講
第一個的話是院長後面要簽字章嗎
可有可無
我是不寫的 我自己不寫
但如果要寫那個可以
一般我自己是不寫 保握時間
因為那不是月券重點
那再來是那個第二題是說
聯絡方式的部分只用圈圈圈可以嗎
可以
應該說不建議 我來看一下好不好
我覺得比較好的 會引起比較好的觀感像這樣子
他作答資訊比較多
這我剛剛沒有改這麼細 同學都會發現
一筆帶過圈圈圈
很難說他錯啦 因為聯絡方式版就是虛擬的
但就是如我剛剛提到觀感不良
我剛剛因為沒有看到
我剛剛平分6分對不對
我如果再次回到這個地方抓狂4分
就是你就不用心了
所以細節上我覺得如果可以做到還是
加檢固一下 讓我們整體觀感會比較好
所以你可以一再的提到一些聽到一些關鍵詞
觀感的問題
神論這一點其實吃的蠻重要
了解
那那個有個同學問是說
請問普通件是不用寫普通嗎
數別嗎
數別要 數別要寫
他剛向這題是數件
題文題叫數卷就應該寫數卷
就要寫數卷
對 要寫普通卷也要寫普通卷
數別不可以空白
那現在再來就是比較像綜合性的問題
譬如說現在有個同學在問說
作文部分大概要拿到幾分是比較保險的呢
做文我們要在今天這地方回答嗎
我們今天是公文
還是下次要再開作文也可以
其實我同學有問啊
就是說那我們未來會不會開作文主題
所以願不願意下次回答
可以啦 今天直播因為是第一次做
我們補習班也是因為疫情這樣比較封閉的關係
開始嘗試這樣的服務
所以要不要開其他的課程 我覺得可能性蠻高
但就是要看回饋跟互動的過程
補習班會有決定 因為這地方也不是我可以決定的
我很樂意服務 但政策上還是要看班內
我可以啦 我可以 我願意 但就看班內
那老師這邊有跟公文相關的 就是說請問公文要抓幾分是目標
12分
12分算強
低於10分的通常就是一定有
通常平均分10分嘛
觀感不好的錯字的話就扣分
觀感好的就11 12
所以如果你到12分我覺得對方對你的印象是好的
然後你也沒有太明顯的錯
抓12分就好啦
那再來的話就有同學問
說如何成為功能高手
那這我們要怎麼修煉這樣
多看多寫啊 多看多寫
然後多看我的直播
直播如果有就盡量看
我覺得是驚豔的
我之所以會用這樣的方式呈現
主要在於
就常看考卷我改卷子的過程
我常這樣想
如果有一個學生他完全沒有上過課
可是他站在我旁邊看我改卷子
我改了一百份之後
我可以保證那個學生就已經會寫了
他可以完全不用上課
但那就是會寫的
那其實就是沒有什麼
什麼地方注意什麼
你常看就會
所以我覺得這也不是開玩笑
如果這樣的東西因為我們時間花了不多
就是你有時間看一下
我覺得在經驗養成上它是會有幫助
老師來了 那問題學花的飛來
老師如果辦法
學花的飛來
如果辦法不是很熟
我已經被洗到辦法掉了
如果辦法不是很熟練
可以說明寫多一點取代
不行 這還沒有講完就知道不行
整體公文的節奏這是簡顯明確
你要在該有的地方出現該有的資訊
你剛剛的說法是 老師我不會寫可不可以避重救星
改的如果內行就不行了
改的會發現 你要讀一把對方要不要發現
像眼前這篇就是啊 他要用那個說明來糊弄辦法
以為我看不出來 看得出來就六分四分
所以我是覺得你在理解的過程還是盡量去理解
然後體文看多一點 不要偷懶
所以剛剛那招我覺得不成立
不成立
在公文很容易被發現
那剛剛老師有回答這個問題
只是說可能同學沒有聽清楚又再問一次
就是說公文要抓幾分是目標
10到12
如果我去考試我會希望我可以考到12分
我會希望我自己12分
我不會希望我低於10分
我如果低於10分我會覺得很可恥
就是學意不盡
12分我滿意的
通常12分是可以考上
有確定了嗎
好
那我們再往下
老師平常如果想問問題可以用IG問你嗎
可以啊但我不一定會回
不要聊那個什麼IG
就這裡聊這裡啊以後都會開直播直播這裡問
別在那邊亂
正本錢空一行請問可以嗎
什麼話啦
有個P同學他在那邊寫說正本錢空一行請問可以嗎
我們再聊一個問題齁
這問題是今天反應最多次 已經快要讓我情緒失控了
欸 控幾個 要不要控一行 要不要控幾個
真正的公文 是控白紙
所以它並沒有控幾個的問題
你拿A4紙跟我說 欸 這個字跟這個字控幾個
A4紙這個字跟這個字控幾個
這個是誰問的一樣 那個
疫苗來的 他不要打
打豬流感
喔好好
那接下來是說
附件跟竹子的中間要控一列
不是同樣問題嗎
同樣問題喔
可控可不控
喔可控可不控
整齊就好
然後
喔同學開始洗好多喔
同學稍等一下喔
小便的訊息一直往上跳
有人在問老子的IG或臉書喔
老師這邊要提供給同學搜索的提示嗎
不要啦 那個我很少再回啦 那個我其實很少在經營
有啦 IG跟臉書我其實主要是寫故事 那是比較文學性的
所以你如果對文學性的
閱讀有興趣的 歡迎你去搜索 你只要打鈴双就好
然後多多鼓勵小弟創作但那個地方可能就不那麼涉入考試 因為會讓就混淆 因為畢竟那是我另一個舞台的發揮我很歡迎你去那個地方追蹤 或者是鼓勵我
或者是對我的協作 有一些指教
但考試我們會就用不同的舞台呈現
你可以不斷的跟出版社跟補習班反應
我們可以開直播 可不可以開什麼的
我都很樂意配合 就是舞台要清楚
我不是不樂意配合啦
但就是我希望生活節奏上可以明白一點
好 那又接下來就是相關的問題 第二頁第一行要空白嗎
我怎麼聽不懂 第二頁第一行空白
第二頁第一行要空白
跨業寫不必 跨業寫不必
跨業寫就順著寫 有格子的地方就可以作答
有格子的地方就可以作答 不用空 不用空
好 那接下來下一個問題是
想請問中間有提到一些抄題是可以的
那抄題比例上多少會影響分數
不一定
他並不是以比例多寡去影響分數
而是以正確性為主
題目有時候確實會放一些
跟提議不相干的說明
所以如果把提議不相干的說明抄進去
就會被扣分
也就是出題者我印這麼多文字就是讓你抄
那我當然會安排一些陷阱
才知道誰抄對誰抄錯
所以並非比例問題
所以公文的作答你不要用長度問題去解他
而是用精確度去解他
所以他吃那個閱讀力喔
老師我同學在港口說
他公文練習很多次啊
但還是拿不到10分以上
老師會怎麼建議同學
我比較好的誠懇的方式
我覺得還是得讓我改你的卷子
我才知道你哪裡錯
像剛剛你看過四份
我真心的認為那些教過來的同學
都覺得自己寫的不錯
他們也會覺得我反正都抄題目
那你看四分五分都有
所以回到我如果沒有看你的作答樣貌
我實在是很難給你一個明確的建議
那如果你真的有這方面的問題
也可以跟我們這個直播平台
我們會有小編
你可以跟他做互動
如果你有更細部分
我們下次聊或把你的問題當成材料來聊都可以
但我們都會匿名
可以發現都是匿名
所以你不用緊張
包括你在網路上你提問
像剛剛我很誇張叫同學打主流感
那也都只是好笑
反正就是網路上
我們以比較輕鬆的方式去帶這個主題
就會好一點
那剛剛老師其實在一段互動的時候
老師剛剛有強調12分啊
同學反應說老師好可愛啊
那如果15分老師給什麼評價
我15分那算是高手
我自己看15分的經驗是
應該是字很漂亮
他除了內容都對
字就超級漂亮
引起很好的觀感
不然就我的
我就彈
以我去考
我就覺得拿12分就好
然後15分
我以前有遇過一個
在台北之光遇到一個
他就拿成績單給我看
他的公文幾分 17分
我沒有看過公文17分的
綁手都沒有 他17分
他拿給我看我當然很開心
說哇 真厲害 真厲害之類的
事實上我心裡面比較想講的話是
17分
給你遇到一個不會改的
不會改的才會給17分這麼高分
不太可能 因為公文可以發現
其實都是抄題目
都是用抄 你給到17分
我覺得有點太誇張了
再欣賞
也要有分寸
就他錯太多 你要有分寸
再好你要分寸 到17分15分我覺得就是
可能對方不會改 或者是你自證太漂亮了
想要以考上為目的 我就覺得設定12分就很理想
然後再有同學問說
請問老師多看公文會有幫助嗎 因為工作的關係會收到很多人的公文
可以
但我怕會扭曲 因為考試公文跟實務公文還是有距離
考試公文跟實務公文還是有距離
所以如果你要看我 就還是看題目啦
看電影
然後再有個同學問說
他格式都沒有錯
但是那個他總是拿7分以下
這跟剛剛反應很像
我得看過才知道
而且話說回來
你說你考試的時候格式都沒有錯
對
你哪來自信
這四個也
他四個很交給我說
我猜他們也覺得他根本都沒有錯
但是也不是否定學生
誰會覺得自己有錯
所以還是改過才知道
所以這是個很好的現象
如果你還是有這方面的問題
就肯定生論都會這樣子
你要是跟小編反應
或者你記你卷子過來
我們去當成素材去聊都可以
所以就像剛剛老師說的
其實國考的公文是批改很嚴格嘛對不對
額..言不嚴格我們不管
它是一個很明顯的正確性
對
我不覺得太嚴格
因為我來看這麼簡單應該都對
但就是為了小瑕疵
哦..了解
然後這邊有同學跟老師告白說
超喜歡老師的文字喔
對對對 可以去看文字
我也喜歡寫啊 所以喜歡閱讀可以去看
那延伸喔 就是說 國考的作文寫作適合參考老師的文章文選喔
就是你那些可能寫的文章文書啊
我覺得間接吧 間接
所有的文字創作到後面我覺得都會相通啦
所以有興趣多看我覺得那不會是壞事
但我那些平台並不是那麼樣的佛考試
好 那這個同學在問說 請問老師台北大學和教育部
今天這變成公文課
請問老師台北大學跟教育部為什麼是平行關係
什麼是通發
台北大學 台北大學
請問台北大學和教育部為什麼是平行關係
上下吧 教育部可以管台北大學
台北大學在一間啊
國立台北大海三峽那個嗎
對啊
大學歸教也不管啊
上下啊不是平行啊
那什麼是通發啊
什麼通發啊
通過的通發型的發
同學問了我傻不了
不好意思啊
問題要具體我聽不懂耶聽不懂
他突然聽到我不知道因為他沒有一個完整的情境
那請TT同學
如果想要再把這個問題深入
再請同學再發一下這樣
小編 盡可能幫你翻譯
清楚一點
那我們再下一題喔
請問受文者如果...
問題這麼多喔
阿對阿
請教...我一直在那邊寫
請問受文者如果超過本行
下一行直接接續寫
還是在冒號以後
冒號以後好問題
冒號以後
好
請問如果先控事業寫公文
結果作文直寫公文
還幾題阿
會扣...
很多喔
還有很多喔
一直來
好 問
那我再重述一次喔
請問如果先控了四頁寫公文
寫作文的
結果公文只寫了三頁會扣分喔
那我聽不懂
他先寫公文喔
他說他先控了四頁寫公文
對 沒錯
不會不會不會
不會不會
不會
看夜第一行控三格再寫嗎
什麼啦
這個好難接了等一下喔
學長我們直播是到幾點嗎
到四點
現在基本上是QA時間
QA好QA
看老師這邊還是老師我拉筋一點
因為這樣子
有些我這樣打很像
沒聲音可以
你換一下
看老師要不要翻譯
我們剛剛到這邊嘛 老師你可以這樣看
老師這樣看得清楚喔
受人者如果超過冒號之後 對
所以HS說如果控了4頁寫公文 作文寫3頁
不會
然後66說跨頁低行 跨頁低行控3格
不一定啦 看你的位置啦
反正你接下一頁永遠是跟前頁的 不一定
我哪知道你寫到哪 有時候跨業有可能還是阻止了 有可能是寫辦法
小編今天有優惠 什麼優惠啦
那個我們已經回了 那老師你就看你覺得是您專業的問題就請老師直接回
需要特別練字機嗎 不太需要 整齊就好
我們剛剛也看過所有可以讓各位同學看就是 我們是看整體的觀感
剛剛有一個就他其實內容都超很棒
我就覺得可以接受
姿態者不會扣分
不會扣分但會觀感不好
過兩年不考公文增加英文比例太可惜
我也覺得很可惜
就是外行人會始終覺得他沒有見別度
我覺得考題就是見別度
他可不可以選出好的人才我覺得可以
或你剛剛看過四篇你也覺得
他很重視閱讀跟條理
那樣的人去當官我覺得是對的
你引力才好不然算了
最後一個
全權含受聞者正本副本 三小
這個喔
這個
受聞者正本副本 聽不到什麼問題拒絕回答
那我們所有問題都沒了
沒有就好啊
那就OK
下次有問題還是可以慢慢問
我們今天就是第一次
就是我要適應 那個同學要適應
就是我們就是用比較
還是站在幫助同學的立場
用這樣樂捲的方式
希望可以給各位一些幫助
有問題就可以慢慢整理
如果出版社覺得這個這樣的活動
是可以持續做的
那我們就可以持續做
如果作文也想聽也可以啦
這都是我滿樂意去做服務的
搞定了嗎
搞定
沒事
掰掰